oh I would think that that would be a
would be very exciting because it would
bring together people of many different
backgrounds and also hopefully people
from the public that are very interested
in science and things that the
literature as well is that the Nobel
represents a very useful thing is being
able to engage directly with the public
so having you know lecture series on a
variety of topics would be would be
really exciting well i think that with
more space and with excellent management
you would be able to i should i just
show the continuity of the story of
science over the past hundred years
through the Nobel prizes I think it's a
fabulous idea now more than ever we all
need to come together and support the
sciences so that we can improve the
future and improve on the human
condition going forward we have a lot of
work to do and I think certainly I'm
very grateful for all the efforts of the
Nobel foundation and the Swedish people
thank you for what you're doing this is
just such an important tribute that you
pay to science and to the human spirit
of discovery
you